all right unsolicited advice I guess so
we got the Super Chat here from Rizzo he
says I've always felt like a woman who
has multiple dogs and no men have issues
ran into a few of them he's a hater he
he's hating on everybody but that's he
feels like there's one in every there's
one in every crowd right yeah but I mean
like I'll be love animals I'll be
completely honest with you if if I was
uh single and dating and I was talking
to multiple options which is how I would
date I would date multiple women
simultaneously in a non monogamous
fashion let the cream rise to the top
and sort of make decisions from there if
I were to come across you chrisy I'd be
like yeah she's goodlooking but dog
thing I don't know man we'll see about
that um three fluffy white yappy dogs
even if they're not yappy fluffy white
dogs got to be useful you know in my
book they got to be able to rip off your
arm and and and like throw it at you
right like I want a dog like that in my
face uh yappy baby dogs not my thing so
um and I know a lot of guys that feel
the same way like we have this
conversation a lot of the times with my
friends so I think that you're limiting
some of your options out there to some
degree
and most of the time women will never
change you know because a guy like me
says something like that they'll be like
well I like my dog so I don't care you
I'll find the right guy but I think you
do limit yourself when you turn your
house into a zoo um I'm not saying three
is a zoo it could turn into a zoo
depending on the size of the house I've
I've been over to a gal's house where it
it smelt like a zoo um so it can be
problematic to be fair one is black so
and here she is fluffy fluffy black dog
whatever they're usually they're usually
like bons or something like that like
you know fluffy white dogs something
like that anyway um sweet girl though
very very sweet Beth um when I was
saying Jack it wasn't a compliment
actually it like the like the muscular
girl thing I know that there's a lot
like I go to the gym and there's a
couple of gals uh close to my age that
are jacked like you can tell that
they've got a hormone doctor and they've
got some testosterone and they're using
a little bit more than what the doctor
wants them to use and they get big yeah
that's a problem yeah um I'm I would I
would caution you to getting too big
because again you know you're going to
limit your options on The Dating
Marketplace because I think generally
speaking the look that most guys
appreciate is sort of like a feminine
Fitness um type of uh physique like a
like a sort of like a model sort of
thing when you're able to flex arms that
are probably the same size as a lot of
guys out there today that don't work out
you're going to limit your options but
at the same time you're probably not
interested in a torp with you know like
a pear-shaped body and skinny arms
anyway so no I'm tall and thick so I
need a guy taller and thicker than me
yeah and there's not a lot of guys like
that that are I mean like over six foot
that's that's less than 14% of the North
American population so if you like tall
you got to go to like Netherlands or
something like that any Dutchman but um
in North America it's less than 14% of
the population so um you know you really
limit yourself when you like big tall
big tall Jack guys I get it though um
again a lot of the opinions fantastic I
think you got your head screwed on
pretty good um but a lot of this is like
you know when the rubber meets the road
sort of thing I would actually encourage
you all you Galls to go to the psyx
channel and watch uh oryan Ty band's
three-part series on how to get the guy
sort of thing because I think it's
really well explained
um it's probably like 45 minutes in
length in total for all three but it's
definitely worth worth checking out Jill
um man Jill Jill the whole the whole bad
decision with the alpha guy 10 years
older than you like a lot of guys have a
hard time looking
past stuff like that um you know I said
earlier during the show like men are
very interested in a woman's past
because women are super interested in
our futures which is totally fine I have
I have nothing wrong with that that but
if you're going to be interested in my
future ability to preside provide
protect you know do all the good stuff
that you know chicks dig I'm going to be
asking questions like okay well she's
bringing another dude's kid to the table
and that guy was all about this that and
the other thing not that you can go in a
time machine or change any of that but
that's that's going to be difficult to
deal with um I don't have an answer to
that other
than try to put some lipstick and makeup
on it and make it look better than
probably what it is um Tiffany you're
you're how old again 24
you got your whole life ahead of you
you're you're sitting on a panel talking
to a bunch
of guys and gals that are dispensing
advice I'm curious how did you take it
all um well I think I got
some uh different point of views from a
couple of the ladies and of you guys of
course um I mean it's something to think
about for my next relationships I guess
but um it's been kind of nice hearing
what everybody else has had to say on
certain um subjects as like the three
main lists we went off of earlier yeah
there's some depth to it still too of
course um you know beyond just be useful
be you know uh awesome in the bedroom
and never ever disrespect him um again
there's a lot of nuances to it and I
think that it's tough today because a
lot of social media narratives like even
though you've got a bass panel we've got
like the anti-woke sort of crowd here
sort of thing I still hear a lot of the
progressive terms like partner uh you
know like our goals together sort of
thing um so some of those narratives are
never ever really going to go away but
um ask questions go down rabbit holes um
ask yourself and ask your friends often
how is that working out for you you know
like past decisions things that they
talk about ideas that they toss around
because you know I find it's always
interesting you know if you're sitting
at a table and a gal's going on and you
know dispensing advice to another gal
sort of thing um but then you sort of
look at the results that they've
acquired as collective of all those
choices and beliefs and you kind of go
like well how's all of that working out
for you right so ask questions um yeah
my friends call that the blind leading
the blind yeah it is it is and there's a
lot of there's a lot of people out there
men and women alike that like to uh uh
talk areas that they would call of
expertise that they are not a master of
at all I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out